es-tu venu à
paris pour le bicentenaire de la révolution française
[Musique]
eh bien il se trouve que je suis ici
mais je suis venu ici pour le spectacle des flux
en 1900 2000 galerie qui appartient à
mass supplys et organisé
si tu me quittes
je n'irai jamais  fais-le
seul
[Musique]
tu es surtout connu comme la femme de jonathan
mais avant ça tu étais déjà un
artiste célèbre
genre oui après nigérian pike
nous aimerions que tu nous expliques sur les
flux
eh bien flexus
est un mot qui a été inventé par george
mcunis
et  il a été inventé avec un sens de l'humour
et je suis sûr que tout ce que vous pensez du
plexus
est vrai, parlez-nous de votre
pièce coupée de performance et de leur
réaction dans différentes capitales oh
la pièce coupée est quelque chose que je ne
vais pas faire  cette fois,
mais je pense que la plupart des gens
connaissent cette pièce
euh c'est pour s'asseoir sur scène
et demander aux gens de couper une
partie de mes vêtements où ils veulent
et de ramener les pièces à la maison donc
et j'aurai une paire de ciseaux
devant moi  et sur  e par un le public est
venu couper mes vêtements
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit parti mais
je pense que j'étais très courageux alors maintenant
je pense que je suis une personne différente votre
film numéro quatre
était de 365 culs
et aussi la bande originale était
les appels téléphoniques des propriétaires  est-ce
vrai
ah oui eh bien euh
oui ça a été fait en 1967
et je pense que les gens l'ont apprécié
c'est un film amusant et tout le
monde en a ri
ce qui est bien avant de rencontrer votre
linge si vous travailliez avec la jeune
cage et nommé jeune
les gens aiment ça oui la première fois que vous avez
fait votre lennon
vous faisiez une pièce d'échelle et un morceau de clou
dans une exposition de galerie n'était-ce pas
bien il y avait une
peinture qui s'appelle la
peinture de clouage hama et
quiconque vient enfoncera simplement
le clou et alors john  est venu
et a dit pourrais-je avoir mon clou et j'ai
dit
non parce que c'est avant l'ouverture
et je veux le garder propre pour l'
ouverture vous savez
et alors il a dit bien alors pourrais-je
enfoncer un clou imaginaire je pensais
que c'était  très doux
et l'idée était similaire à ce que je faisais
conceptuel donc j'ai pensé que c'était comme ça que nous avons
rencontré
ce qui a été votre recette secrète pour
épouser un scarabée marié
je n'ai jamais eu de liaison avec une personne mariée
et je n'ai pas
pensé à euh perturber le  mariage ou
quelque chose comme ça mais j'étais un artiste
et il était un artiste et
nous avons eu une rencontre de l'âme dirons-nous
et le fait que nous étions mariés à
des personnes différentes à l'époque euh n'était pas
un souci
quand nous nous sommes réunis mais plus tard  c'est devenu
une préoccupation bien sûr
est-il vrai que tu étais responsable de
l'esprit des
beatles alors je dois être une femme très puissante
mais je ne pense pas que je devrais prendre
un tel crédit
qu'ils étaient des amis très forts
et je pense qu'ils  juste
dépassé la période dans laquelle ils étaient,
pensez-vous que
le fan de scarabée aurait été en colère contre
vous si vous étiez marié à
un mâle blond guêpe peut-être que
je ne sais pas, nous ne le saurons jamais, mais c'est
vrai que j'étais un
bouc émissaire très pratique parce que  de ce que je suis
ou  ce que j'étais ce qui s'est passé
en tant que femme et en tant qu'oriental est-
il vrai que vous avez arrangé
l'histoire d'amour entre john et
son assistant pantalon bien
je ne sais pas je veux dire je ne pense pas que c'était
un
arrangement c'était pratique pour john  avoir une
assistante quand il va à la
et elle était une très bonne assistante une
personne très capable donc c'était bien qu'elle soit
allée à la avec lui
si julian john et son premier fils attendaient toujours de l'
argent de vous maintenant euh
la situation de confiance
avec julian était  mis en place euh par john
et c'est géré par des avocats
selon lui
auriez-vous préféré que mark
chapman reçoive une condamnation à mort
eh bien
euh quoi que nous fassions joan ne reviendra pas
tu sais
et euh c'est le sujet auquel je préfère
ne pas penser
peut-être un  jour je pourrais y penser mais c'est quand
même très pénible pour moi est-il vrai
que tu n'as
rien changé dans la chambre du général à dakota
n'est-ce pas bizarre ce n'est pas vrai
la chambre que nous avons utilisée
n'est pas l'animal j'ai
tout plié et le  la pièce est utilisée
pour autre chose
[Musique]
je ne veux pas
garder un sanctuaire dans ma maison ou quelque chose
comme ça et aussi je n'ai pas à sa
mémoire est là
moi et ses souvenirs en moi
donc ce n'est pas ce que je veux  faire
avec il y a tellement de photographes et de
gardes du corps
pensez-vous que sean aurait été un
enfant plus heureux
s'il était pauvre et inconnu
je pense que sean ne connaît que la vie
qu'il connaît
et donc dans cette vie bien sûr il y
avait aussi beaucoup de
situations difficiles  mais j'espère
qu'il va être un garçon heureux
êtes-vous toujours en contact avec paul george
et ringo
[Musique]
eh bien, nous possédons ensemble une entreprise qui
s'appelle Apple
et nous devons donc bien l'exploiter ensemble,
nous devons avoir un son négatif,
nous sommes  fonctionne et nous faisons du très
bon travail,
donc parfois nous discutons de choses
et nous faisons du bon travail, qu'est
-ce que ça fait d'être riche de 150 millions de dollars,
je n'ai jamais vraiment compté mon argent
et je suis sûr
c'est une estimation qui
estime beaucoup  des choses qui existent, je
pense toujours que peut-être
que ce journaliste parlait de la
valeur de mon cerveau
et auquel cas c'est très flatteur avez-
vous dit que
je ne sais pas si je serais à nouveau heureux le
bonheur est une situation comparative et
aussi
c'est  quelque chose que nous devons créer
pour nous
-mêmes et j'espère que je pourrai
profiter de la vie et je
n'aurais jamais dû [Musique]